let's do some more percentage problems
let's say that
i start this year in my stock portfolio
with
95 dollars
and i say that my portfolio portfolio
grows
by
let's say 15 percent
how much do i have now
have now
okay i think you might be able to figure
this out on your own but of course we'll
do some example problems just in case
it's a little confusing so i'm starting
with 95 and i'll get rid of the dollar
sign we know we're working with dollars
95 dollars right
and i'm going to earn or i'm going to
grow just because i was an excellent
stock investor i that 95 is going to
grow by 15 percent
so
to that ninety five dollars i'm going to
add another 15 of 95. so we know we
write 15 percent as a decimal as 0.15
so 95 plus 0.15
of 95 so this times 95 that dot is just
a time sign it's not a decimal it's a
times it's a little higher than a
decimal
so 95 plus 0.15 times 95 is what we have
now right because we started with 95
dollars and then we made another 15
percent times what we started with
hopefully that makes sense another way
we say the 95 dollars has grown by 15
percent
so let's just work this out this is the
same thing as 95
plus
what's 0.15 times 95
let's see
so let me hopefully have enough space
here 95
times
0.15 i don't want to run out of space
let me do it up here i think i'm about
to run out of space
times .15
5 times 5 is 25
9 times 5 is 45 plus 2 is 47
1 times 95 is 95
bring down the 5 12 carry the 1
and how many decimals do we have 1 2
15.25 is that right i think i made a
mistake here
see
5 times 5 is 25
5 times 9 is 45
plus 2 is 47
and we're putting a zero here
that's 95
right 1 times 5 1 times 9
and then we add 5 plus 0 is 5 7 plus 5
is 12.
oh see i made a mistake it's
14.25 not 15.25
so i'll ask you an interesting question
how did i know that that 15.25 was a
mistake
well i did a reality check
i said well i know in my head that 15
percent of a hundred is fifteen so
fifteen percent of a hundred is fifteen
how can fifteen percent of ninety-five
be more than fifteen
i think that might have made sense i the
bottom line is ninety-five is less than
a hundred so fifteen percent of 95 had
to be less than 15. so i knew my answer
15.25 was wrong and so it turns out that
i actually made an addition error and
the answer is 14.25
so the answer is going to be 95 plus 15
percent of 95 which is the same thing as
95 plus
14.25
so 95
plus 14.25
well that equals 109
0.25
109.25
notice how easy i made this for you to
read especially this 2 here
109.25 so if i start off with 95 and my
portfolio grows or the amount of money i
have grows by 15 percent i'll end up
with 109
dollars and a quarter
let's do another problem
let's say
i start off with some amount of money
and after a year let's see
my portfolio grows
my portfolio
grows
and after after growing 25 percent
i now have
um let's say i now have
dollars how much did i originally have
notice i'm not saying that the hundred
dollars is growing by 25 percent i'm
saying that i start with some amount of
money
it grows by 25 percent
and i end up with a hundred dollars
after it grew by 25 percent
to solve this one we we might have to
break out a little bit of algebra
so let x
equal
what i start with
so just like the last problem i start
with x
and it grows by 25 percent so x plus
25 percent
of x
is equal to 100 and we know this 25
percent of x we can just rewrite as x
plus
.25
of x
is equal to 100
and now actually we have a level
actually this might be a level three
system a level three um
a linear equation but the bottom line we
can just add the coefficients on the x
so here we x is the same thing as 1x
right so 1x plus 0.25x well that's just
the same thing as 1 plus 0.25
x we're just doing the distributive
property in reverse
equals 100 and what what's 1 plus 0.25
that's easy it's 1.25
so you say 1.25
x
is equal to
100.
not too hard and after you do a lot of
these problems you're going to
intuitively say oh if some number grows
by
25 percent and it becomes 100 that means
that 1.25 times that number is equal to
100.
and if if this doesn't make sense
sitting think about a little bit maybe
re-watch the video and and hopefully
it'll over time uh start to make a lot
of sense to you and this is not this
type of math is very very useful i
actually i work at a hedge fund and i'm
doing this type of math in my head day
and night
so 1.25 times x is equal to 100
so
x
would equal
divided by 1.25 i just realized you
probably don't know what a hedge fund is
i invest in stocks for a living anyway
back to the math
so x is equal to 100 divided by 1.25 so
let me make
some space
here
just because i used up too much space
let me get rid of my little let x
statement actually i think we
we know what x is and we know how we got
to the
there if you forgot how we got there you
can i guess rewatch the video
let's see now let me make the pen
thin again
and go back to the orange color
okay x equals 100 divided by 1.25 so we
say 1.25
goes into
point zero 100.00
i'm going to add a couple of zero i
don't know how many i'm going to need i
probably added too many if i move this
decimal over
two
to the right i need to move this one
over two to the right
right
and i say
well how many times is 100 going 100 how
many times does 125 go into 100 none how
many times does it go into a thousand it
goes into it eight times
i happen to know that in my head but you
could do trial and error and think about
it 8 times
if you want to think about 8 times 100
is 800 and then 8 times 25 is 200 so it
becomes a thousand
you could work it out if you like but i
think i'm running out of time so i'm
going to do this fast
8 times 125 is 1000
remember this this thing isn't here
one thousand
so one thousand my thousand is zero
so you can bring down the zero 125 goes
into zero zero times
and we just keep getting zeros this is
just a decimal division problem
so it turns out that if your portfolio
grew by twenty five percent and you
ended up with a hundred dollars you
started
with eighty dollars
and that makes sense because twenty 25
is roughly 1 4 right so if i start with
80 and i grow by 1 4 that means i grew
by 20 because 25 of 80 is 20.
so if i start with 80 and i grow by 20
that gets me to 100
makes sense so remember all you have to
say is well
some number times 1.25 because i'm
growing it by 25
is equal to 100. don't worry if you're
still confused i'm going to add at least
one more presentation on a couple of
more examples like this